did you think rock star was done  supporting grand theft auto 5 guess  again because the team has announced  another new adversary mode for GTA  online and it's available right now it's  called rhino hunt and it's a total David  versus Goliath game mode one team rides  around in Rhino military tanks decked  out with tough armor and big guns  meanwhile a much bigger team drives  weaker vehicles like dune buggies as  they try to destroy the tanks with  sticky bombs sounds like a pretty  chaotic multiplayer mode and you can  play it at three locations across Los  Santos including the airport most GTA  online updates like this are exclusive  to the ps4 xbox one and pc versions of  the game so don't be surprised if that  turns out to be the case here rockstar  also announced some discounts and  experience bonuses if you play the new  mode by March 3rd for now keep it locked  to gamespot we promise we won't throw  any sticky bombs at you